- La période des Fêtes
s'annonce encore une fois
corsée cette année.
Mais nnnne nouvelle, le virus
respiratoire syncytial, qui se
répand de manière fulgurante
chez les enfants, aurait atteint
le pic de sa courbe et
sa transmission sera
actuellement en baisse.
Malheureusement, la tendance
s'inverse dans le cas de
l'influenza et de la COVID-19.
Dr LUC BOILEAU, directeur
national de la santé publique
- On sait que le mois de
décembre devrait être difficile
pour l'influenza. On s'attend
à ce que le pic soit dans
le mois de décembre.
On est plus nombreux à
l'intérieur, on magasine
plus nombreux à l'intérieur.
On a des partys de bureaux,
des réceptions comme ça, il y a
plus de risques. Là, on se
le dit, c'est important :
essayons de tous se protéger.
- Se protéger avec les gestes
barrières habituels;
comme le port du masque dans
des lieux fermés et achalandés,
et la vaccination contre
la grippe et la COVID-19.
Parallèment aux urgences qui
débordent, dans les écoles du
Québec, le taux d'absentéisme,
lui, s'élève à 12,7 %, soit
plus que le double de la moyenne
pré-COVID.
Avec 158 000 élèves absents
au primau u u u secondaire,
à la formation professionnel
et l'éducation des adultes.
NICOEEEÉVOST, prés. Fédé.
québéc. dir. d'établissement
- Les parents qui gardent plus
enenenenfants à la maison
aussitôt qu'ils ont des
symptômes, donc ils vont lesrdr,
c'est que nos enfants sont plus
fragiles pour... après deux ans
de pandémie, avec certaines
mesures sanitaires, dont le port
du masque.
MÉLANIE HUBERT, prés. Fédération
autonome de l'enseignement (FAE)
- C'est difficile de conjuguer
tous les jours avec un certain
pourcentage d'élèves absents,
là. Il faut penser envoyer du
travail à la maison, s'ajuster
le matin même quand on se rend
compte qu'il manque le tiers
ou la moitié d'une classe.
- Avec les trois virus
respiratoires en circulation